haro sur l'huile de palme vous l'ignorez
peut-être mais en quelques années cette
matière grasse s'est imposé dans
l'agroalimentaire gâteau plats cuisinés
lait en poudre elle est omniprésente car
peu chers et faciles à transporter mais
voici le retour de bâton la culture de
l'huile de palme est trop souvent
synonyme de déforestation et surtout
surtout le produit lui-même serait
beaucoup trop riches en acides gras
saturés
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé sophie mais el cid hennebert coup
voici l'arbre de toutes les polémiques
c'est en pressant les fruits de ce
palmier que l'on obtient de l'huile de
palme
une production extrêmement rentable qui
conduit les agriculteurs d'indonésie et
de malaisie où se concentre sa culture à
brûler la forêt pour y installer leurs
plantations
le phénomène a largement été dénoncée
par les écologistes
mais depuis peu certains pensent avoir
trouvé une parade l'huile de palme
durable
une huile qui ne peut provenir que des
surfaces agricoles existantes et non de
la déforestation
c'est ce que défend depuis des années le
wwf
depuis 2008 l'huile de palme durable et
sur le marché ce qui fait que l'on peut
utiliser de l'huile de palme durable
il ya la production actuelle
actuellement est environ 2 7 5 5 7 25%
de l'ensemble de la production mondiale
est une huile de palme durable
c'est le choix de ce fabricant belge de
matières grasses
philippe thierry son pdg qui vérifie ici
l'onctuosité de cette margarine utilise
de l'huile de palme dans pratiquement
tous ses produits
qu'est ce que vous faites là alors là on
fait un test de pouce aux maîtrises donc
on regarde quelle est la dureté mais
surtout quel est l'apport ch'ti citer
ces briques vont servir à la cuisson des
viandes et des légumes
cette pâte visqueuse à la fabrication
des biscuits et biscottes des produits à
destination de l'industrie ou de la
restauration
tous vont progressivement être certifié
développement durable pour un coût
supplémentaire de 2 à 3 euros seulement
il faut tâcher d'abord pour ne pas
déforester d'utiliser l'huile qui a le
meilleur rendement à l'hectare et là
c'est l'huile de palme il vaut mieux
prendre une huile de palme certifiée
parce que sinon vous n'aurez pas
d'alternative on sait plus faire la
croissance est plus faire une gaufre on
sait plus faire un vol au vent et à
toute une série de produits où on n'a
pas d'autre alternative car l'huile de
palme demeure la seule huile solide à
température ambiante
quand toutes les autres colza maïs soja
et tournesol sont liquides
une spécificité qui apporte de la
texture et de l'onctuosité et que
l'industrie aujourd'hui ne peut pas
remplacer
d'ailleurs lorsque vous faites vos
courses pour le petit déjeuner biscotte
céréales pâtes à tartiner lilloise riz
vous ne vous doutez pas que ces produits
industriels ont pratiquement tous un
point commun ils contiennent de l'huile
de palme et c'est pareil pour tous les
repas de la journée
cette huile se cache même là où on la
soupçonne le moins dans le bios et même
dans le lait pour nourrissons c'est
aujourd'hui la première huile consommée
au monde
certains nutritionnistes comme le
docteur boris ans elles sont inquiètes
car si l'on en consomme trop elle peut
être néfaste pour la santé
huile de palme contient 50 % d'acides
gras saturés ce qu'on appelle les
mauvaises graisses
quand l'huile d'olive en contient 15 %
et l'huile de colza seulement 8 % des
graisses saturées d'une part augmente
loto de cholestérol de manière très
puissante et deuxièmement la
consommation en graisses saturées est
associée au risque de développer des
maladies comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires certains cancers
notamment le cancer du sein et certaines
maladies neurologiques comme la maladie
d'alzheimer
pour ce médecin le message est clair il
faut prendre des bonnes habitudes
alimentaires très tôt donc moi je
déconseille dès l'enfance de consommer
manière trop importante des graisses
saturées notamment des aliments riches
en huile de palme
peut-on pour autant s'en passer nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de findus
qui a opté pour un choix radical
l'industriel installé à boulogne sur mer
a décidé de bannir l'huile de palme de
l'ensemble de ses produits
les bâtonnets de poisson blanc le
produit phare sont aujourd'hui free avec
de l'huile de colza
résultat les graisses saturées ont
baissé entre 50 et 80% selon les
produits pour valider ce choix il
fallait tout d'abord que le goût ne
change pas c'est ce que vérifier
régulièrement matthieu lambeaux
directeur général de findus france et
instigateur de cette petite révolution
mais il a aussi fallu s'adapter d'un
point de vue industriel de colza nous
demande un peu plus de d'attention de la
mise en place de deux nouveaux systèmes
pour notamment la cuisson et après une
surveillance extrêmement importante
puisqu'on change maintenant l'huile tous
les cinq heures de 5 à 7 heures ce
n'était pas le cas auparavant
si fin du ca pue substituer tout son
huile de palme c'est parce qu'il
utilisait en friture à pour son
onctuosité ou sa texture tous les
industriels ne pouvons pas suivre son
exemple
[Musique]